previously on Bigfoot I think we're bad
at this is the thing and the thing is
I've killed Bigfoot before by myself so
I I have no excuse I agree I don't think
ever successfully killed Bigfoot I
thought we got him once didn't we know
we got the chupacabra or whatever it was
the rig just carry the trap around
yeah I'm carrying a trap what of it
maybe we should start just leaving
baited traps around everywhere and hope
that you know he hits them yeah yeah I
could leave I could leave a couple we
should also keep looking for points of
interest on the map for supplies what do
you think we're doing what do you think
we're amateurs here yeah whoa oh oh
speaking of points of interest gonna
help all right
you change the terms of the deal are you
deadly how do I heal it huh huh what oh
thank you I don't know what I did you
saved my life me life you're welcome Oh
person well I mean some of the person
yeah does that count well he left one
leg intact can we get the meat off of
that leg to use for our yeah how do I
get meat no for me yeah it's a little
orange for me yeah like blood like
almost well he seems to be going back up
to his northwest corner all right I'm
gonna go right here on South right yes
Chad put a camera here so we can take a
look at you oh my god I'm sorry is that
not good for me come on put it back put
it back down I don't know if that's the
best idea but okay I can do this dick
crew Ok Go I'm ready tricks all right
yeah nice
was this yeah yeah yeah yeah okay don't
body block who are you scooby-doo
huh then how are you doing he's doing
all right any woods you came in are you
doing all right in the woods are you
Ethan it may be a clip that and send it
to Ethan and he will be shocked that
he's speaking with himself Kankakee
speaking to you
Zeke ranked game plays I did I thought
we'd died absolutely fit I promise are
you sure okay all right well oh wow
no wait wait wait we got signs old mine
where's the wait I don't know where it's
way this is actually pointing it's this
path right yeah I felt just in time to
do nothing thanks buddy I got the meat
don't worry guys this can't fire heal me
does that have any benefit whatsoever I
don't know what if we cook meat and eat
meat to heal could that be a thing cook
me need me let's cook me need me deal
will heal I can take the fire Oh God all
right there we go we got fire hey Beck
again just thought I'd tell you all the
everything cook to me I'm going to the
mine I'm right behind you yeah sure
you're I'm inside Wade just way back
forever with us Settlers of Catan oh I
just recorded a new series on it Wow
oh I see a house I see a house too you
were right
thanks buddy we got more flares why
don't we use so many flares
where's the bullets body around the back
oh yeah that's the body all right
oh Emily Jones all right so I'm not one
to like call out genders and I guess I
shouldn't assume but Emily is Emily a
thick one well he's pretty thick well I
mean not anymore but maybe this is just
really puffy pants Oh like the cadaver
has swollen I get sure yeah apply it
directly oh wait I found the mine
entrance
hey bullets hey there's bullets in here
Bob yeah I'm coming
are you out of bullets Bob completely
I'd like to take the other box the box
friend yeah guys we all have bullets
good yeah I must just stabbed you but
I'm afraid it would actually happen
you're afraid that stabbing me who I
actually stab me like it yeah right in
real life you live in a spooky house man
that's honestly not wrong and if I got
more meat I have one meat he's gonna put
a trap down and yeah yeah the traps
still there he hasn't taken the bait
he's gotten smarter he used to be real
dumb I liked it better when Bigfoot was
dumb where's your trap gonna be boss I
don't have any more traps do you huh huh
yeah I have a trap you want me a trap it
boss yeah if you could yeah subordinate
should I meet his trap yeah meat it up
you free go to the bathroom can you make
sure I don't die No gotcha
I've got you like I'm like great I'll be
released I don't know what that means
Oh hear that wolf or it ah no I don't
know if the wolf sounds actually
correlate the real wolf wolves with a
fee
okay I'm back am i dead no everything's
fine all right good good great good good
good great okay cool
did he go for the traps no okay um let's
keep her moving then I guess keep
removing what he's a keeper looping or
keep removing keep or moving keep keep
moving keep for keeper moving free maybe
let's keep freeing guys keep freeing
moving keep the Prix going worried dear
to the left of us somewhere I heard it I
don't see it uh due north somewhere in
there well you hear oh thanks for the
warning also
I've got 14 I have 13 taken Bob heard a
bark bark poppy whoa please just be like
taking this Shawn can you please just be
like I'm shooting something like that
way I gotta go right then yeah you can
say shooting you said something before
you shot so there was clearly time for
you to say something before you shot
alright I'll try to save more times
cuz you litter all you do is like oh I
think I hear a wolf in the face you need
a first aid I will I've got two
first-aid kits apparently killing my
dead body
you stepped on my trap you bastard I'm
on the way I'm running out of stamina
okay coming coming coming
I was just about to use a bit I
literally had gotten the bandage out oh
alright whoa trap hello yeah there's a
trap there I tried to he literally
walked over it like how do we get him to
go in the trap I don't know I think we
just gotta be smarter about it he's
coming back there he is on he's back
he's back guys guys guys guys okay I'm
dying you just try to knife him did you
really just try to go knife him are you
yeah
don't you nod your head at me can you at
least explain why you tried to knife him
because he was close guys alright wait
tell me how many times you hit him if he
was so close there was less than seven
times oh yeah is it more than two more
than one was it less than one right
that's what I thought okay hi Bob yes
what can I do for you look right this
looks good I know how we can check up on
this progress did you doesn't work
anyway I'll baskis for you don't worry
about it thank you good kind sir these
will definitely work everything's fine
yeah all right man anyway alright well
that was productive maybe we should just
all take a nap turn this light on have a
good time
turn on the light take a nap like guys
that's cool boy how do you my tired
let's turn these lights on guys did he
break them over here the trainer is
wearing off or has worn off no he's down
there okay well I think he's coming this
way so oh no he's going towards he's
going towards the trap which one is he
by this one this one I think I have a
good feeling about it
he's definitely gonna be coming here
he's definitely coming this way I feel
it what this camera zoomed right it on
YouTube what I don't know an avid mark
it's confusing I tried to shoot weight
and I don't know
accident all right something's going on
here someone's messing with me and I
think it's Wade are you doing
Thank You Man are you doing to me hey
I'm looking at you through my tablet
rather than looking directly in the eye
here don't have you tonight I got you
again with the old behind-the-back er
yeah yeah I knew it was you I knew it
was you the whole time that's right it
was me you can't see it why that's what
you get you wouldn't do that a third
yeah a third time I did it once so I
won't do it a third time
[Laughter]
wait a trick question all right so how
do we catch this bad boy well I think I
think what we're supposed to do is
gather supplies meet back ok face set
all the traps out you know big line and
then get them through sheer force of
attrition they run straight through all
of our own traps yes exactly exactly
well I mean that if you do have enough
meat to line three up lit some line
three I by this fence at the crest of
this hill he should be hit by them like
he just should right like here in a line
with the fence Mason I think so just
closing off one way that he could
possibly go around them so then he
should come this way and even if he sees
us it's okay because there's no way he
could miss way do you have any traps
yeah yeah just keep going in the line
because it's either not it wait you know
actually I think that's actually okay
because I literally he stepped right
over one away okay you want to have like
a dense grouping yeah we're gonna get
him this time his ass is grass what is
this
what is his ass guys well what's his ass
I studied the the documents his ass it's
not weed the grass yeah wait aren't
these the dead bodies of the of the
Scout something like pile of dead bodies
no no no no that's a pickle did you hear
that do I look cool oh oh oh god it's
the raccoon wait I hate it on there I
hate
[Laughter]
you're gonna lose the kill
that's why I'm the hunter and you're the
gatherer you did - you did multiple
things that make me hate you
you didn't call out that you were
shooting and then as soon as I'm like I
have scoping on like alright you got it
I freaking hope Bigfoot eats you alive
from the legs up no build-up no elegance
to it just like dude here take my whoa
whoa there have a 10 I'm going to my
tent
I never mind I'm gonna buy 10 here we go
open I'm going in I can't I put it where
I can't go in get my 10 it's gonna be my
10 none of you go near my tent okay go
to my tent hi how's it going
privacy here close this window this old
I don't want people looking in here
oh god I'm stuck oh god I'm so stuck
alright good morning
oh [ __ ] oh wait rumbling you hear that
yeah I'm gonna build my guys I have a
safety tent over here you can't actually
get inside of it though it's no prob
that's pretty safe that means he can't
either yeah no one can get inside of it
no I gave it to you I gave I know you
did not Mark Waid lost my pen I don't
know how that happened and I don't care
wait lost my tail I don't care you lost
it I don't care I don't care
you've lost my ten I'll give you my
tenth if you'll shut up about it and he
didn't lose it he just stole it now he's
being an ass you know this to be true
dude get on my back
do you see it that oh you do see it then
yeah you don't have one I don't have one
what but I gave you one of course you'll
have one no you still have one on your
ass no I gave you it's not a bob you got
one uh no you don't I do have one I had
one cuz I gave you one
where's Bigfoot oh wait no I hear
Bigfoot oh he's there oh God I'm up I
feel young again
okay laying down the job there you know
I didn't get the nap in that tent for me
man those traps sure worked good night
I'm just gonna see if Wade has anything
I want I can't heal you
oh I can't how many things to heal you
guys did you try feeling us okay all
right I know how to end this one you
guys wait wait
yeah yeah yeah that's not enough to kill
me try again try again really got really
got a jackass this up gonna put a camp
fire here right yeah you see you know
you get your traps out and then you pull
the flare right right of course I like
the lighting effect
oh hey Bob you're fine to kill Bob we'll
be dead dumbasses now let's end this
[Applause]
fireworks standing in actual fire oh
good oh cool the opening cinematic or
the closing cinematic oh we did it well
done guys yeah great football Bigfoot
damage or oh yeah this is Bigfoot damage
trap since taled cramp didn't stain lion
scaled 5 traps guys all right good job
good good work well that was a real
that's a winner the winner we did it we
did I feel proud of us and myself
especially
[Music]